get you one of these man
it's easy keep your bank cards in this
and I sell these for 29.99
but anybody in the studio need one of
these I got them for the low
what's up GQ I'm country Wayne these are
10 Things I can't live without
[Music]
so this right here this is my Bible case
girl had got it for me one time she seen
the Bible you got that Bible in there
that's my niece Bible that I took when I
was in the streets and I was going
through some things I want to get out I
ain't have no bible to read and this was
the easy one to read it ain't got all
the big words like that now need knocked
out and them on there and then this
Bible right here my daughters gave me
some fake money they gave us a fake
money one day for my birthday this is my
blessing book my probation officer gave
me this when I when I was on probation
she put me on to writing your blisses
down every day so this my Jesus popping
blessing book right here I write down my
blessings every day
cheat right now with something good
happened that day so I won't think about
the bad stuff yesterday I wrote thank
God for waking me up this morning for
allowing me to be a blessing to us thank
God for allowing me to be healthy if
allow me to be a part of you I thank God
for allowing me to film 15 skits because
that's how I make that money yeah I
thank God for allowing me to make
passive income Jesus is popping yeah
[Music]
my next essential is my phone see my
phone is
really good this is very essential in my
life right here this the main phone
people call just a phone that I got an
industry number that I don't really
answer like that and if this the phone I
shoot with videos on right here all my
online content any famous people on your
phone oh yeah I got a famous people in
my phone top five probably said you're
Entertainer E40 for sure let's see who
else I talked to drewski um we got DC
just hilarious
yeah my top five
yeah
my molecule it's my wallet right here
if you went to school you know what this
is shout out to a white Baker I know
named Effie when my credit score was 500
and I went to the bank and he gave me a
loan I had all them cars in my pocket I
had a big while he said man it's all you
need right here
hey this is the same one right here for
2008 shot the Spivey bank I should have
shot it out because they're probably
gonna get in trouble for giving that
bank loan with that 500 credit score but
we got a little business card right here
the scope I still got a Discover card
and I'm a celebrity I ain't boozy it
ain't that much money on either American
Express Skyline another Discover Card
I've been here though Wells Fargo
American Express yeah got some paper on
this too now you gotta have got a little
cash on us too you know what I'm saying
I'm a country boy so we're gonna keep a
little bit on this now oh this GQ I
don't keep this on me I forgot you know
the whole National interview I just put
out of cash yeah that one real
[Music]
my nourishment is that spin it right
here just you know I'm a vegan so I have
to eat my um get my um like Popeye
that's how I get my nerves
[Applause]
got the water we do the Icelandic we got
the chips these are oh these these
barbecues right here now this is like
the Chipotle kettle cooked potato chips
right here we got the organic carrot we
got to get the organic it's Mary Poppins
band
this this is that bag right here
and this right here the main thing that
a lot of people in the world be
forgetting about
stay gone
you know just the perm and not to laugh
it gets done
yeah so there's that Pro right here
everybody got to use that part if you
ain't got that purr you probably got
that air
Vanessa Center is my jerk the drip you
know right we got the Jesus popping
chain so this is Jesus popping with the
BBS shout out to ice box right here
claritel the diamond we got the Jesus
Papa ring right here
Jesus popping right here
help is on the way then we got the KW at
the top this that pinky ring because I
don't have a wedding ring yeah that's
how I'm rocking it's the presidential
just the presidential Rollie with the
Flawless diamonds in the east coast
Factory it's the clearest to get right
here y'all camera catching the clarity
and these right here
got to have them just to give you a
little
bro this is GQ this the upper echelon
[Music]
yeah hello
dinner floss that's right you gotta have
this gotta keep them teeth right and we
use the hello kind you know it's got a
lot of natural things in it for those at
home don't know how to use it
sometimes that funk from their breath
not even coming from the tongue you
gotta get between those cracks
for those grown people out there who
don't know you take lunch rabbit rabbit
going now
[Music]
please the whole world we need to floss
together I pray that through this
interview just become everybody's
essential amen
[Music]
my next essential is my new book help is
on the way oh maybe we want to write a
book man
um it was just my life story and I
wanted people to understand where I was
coming from you come from the streets
still be where you at but still be
positive so I'm like man how you stay
positive through all that and I went
through a lot and I feel like the world
needs to hear the help is on the way
country Wayne I feel like the world
needs to hear that man that's a lot of
lessons and blessings in there but one
of the main ones I want to call out is
stay up
that's for everybody I tell women a man
to get tired of a woman
who put too much to him he'll never get
tired of a woman who put too much into
her and we would be like oh
take care of yourself put yourself first
cause long as you stay up you won't
matter how people feel about you anytime
somebody can text you and change your
day I'd be seeing people like if
somebody got the power to teach you and
change your whole day
You Ain't Know
[Music]
my next essential is my cars
uh some of the favorite cars this
Cadillac Escalade key right here goodbye
I always want that Cadillac Escalade
truck since I was young you know I just
love the way it's big but it got that a
nice flow to it this right here it's the
Maybach Keys Maybach truck when it came
it was bouncing I'm gonna caught that
the key that's not here right now is the
black badge Rolls-Royce truck the color
in it it's pink it's crucial but I call
it Pinky don't country so it ain't pink
I say pinky
on my first car 2000 Crown Victoria but
hey put them things on it it had them
22s right Country Boy red and yellow was
like Ronald McDonald
[Music]
my hair products right here we got the
Laughing here
I'm not a pronounce it but it's a left
field to the hands the curls you know
what I'm saying you hit it with a child
and then you take you take the pick you
know saying you take the pick and
you hit it with that and then we got the
old African-American sponge that we
don't took over take this you hit it
with that
that and you good get it right real
quick gotta take care of that haircut I
think that's one of the things women
don't tell you that they really like
they love to see the essence of your
hair grow out of you see men men don't
think that because ego think we could
just do anything no man you gotta take
care of yourself but I'm single so I
stay up I know the game
my necessary is my brothers
my team
yup so this is Prince stay right here
this is RB like the restaurant
a-r-b-y they help with everything the
kids or the baby mamas keep them you
know so if they need something they call
it's something to be done paperwork
Rises
so they kind of handle everything
hey man it's your boy country Wayne I
appreciate y'all for watching GQ country
Wayne my 10 essential house yeah